hey what's up guys my name is a Chennai
welcome to episode 23 of game
programming so yesterday we were pretty
damn awesome and we drew this grass
texture but the problem was we couldn't
actually move right if I hit it over
there steak haze or the air okay so
we're not moving so today we're actually
gonna cover how we move around our
little creation here but more
specifically you know how how we plan to
navigate maps in this game because I
feel that I feel that that's something
that needs to be covered in depth and um
and yeah let's just jump into it
so we have a few different things set up
here right and there are a bunch of
comments there are a bunch of things
that we're not using there's just so
much stuff that I'm literally just gonna
delete everything and make it just the
bare essentials so this is what is
actually in you so you can say that this
these pretty much three lines of code
here or well actually this one line of
code is what renders the entire game
right now okay so how do we actually
navigate around it if we go back into
our game class you can see that the way
we actually sort of navigate is we
increase and decrease x and y values
based on which arrow key we hit or which
key we hit basically so the WASD Keys
whatever
if we hit the key to go up we subtract
numbers from Y if we go down then we add
if we go left we subtract from X and if
we go right we add to X and we actually
plug in these variables into the
parameters for our screen don't random
method which is right over here so there
are offsets now in order to actually
apply the offsets to here we have to do
a few things right basically what it is
is we're saying the pixels wishes what
gets drawn our screen need to be offset
bias by a specific amount right based on
where we are in the map so the way we
can do that is simply by saying that X
will actually be X plus X offset right
because if the offset is negative 10 for
example so we've gone left 10 pixels it
will be X plus minus 10 which will be X
minus 10 which will be whatever X's
minus 10 correct yeah and same with y so
y plus y offset and what I will do is
actually use these parameters to set the
offset for the map so in other words to
tell our game to tell to basically
display the map in its correct position
based on where we are in it now
obviously this isn't exactly gonna work
as intended in the final game I mean
it's gonna work but it's not gonna work
as it will when we finish with it and
the reason for that is we've only built
one portion of the map when all right we
are actually built a map yet all we've
done it we've just repeated values yeah
we haven't actually done something
that's why it's not gonna you know
really work as well hang on well it will
work obviously but did just fine if we
hit this in fact I'll probably crash if
I try and move just because X actually
exceeds the correct amount so what I
actually do here is I'll say that if X
is less than 0 or X is greater than or
equal to width then let's continue and
I'll do I'll copy and paste it up and
I'll do the same for y so Y actually
should have been up here
and if I preview that and you can whoop
it crashed again and the reason actually
crashes because it was an offset so I'll
I'll have to fix this up real quick
instead of having that that that code
was just there to sort of demonstrate
how how it works what I'll do now is
I'll actually make this I'll simplify
that into one variable so I'll make a
variable for y we'll call it int Y pace
and just Y pixel equals y plus y offset
so in other words this is exactly what's
written here and it will actually
replace this with Y pay which is the
variable we just created and same with
this X plus F X plus X offset is not
going to become X paid and we'll pop
that right into here just like that all
right
and why did we do that that we did that
so that we could actually make sure that
XP and YP oops
why pay up here and I did that just so
we can make sure that XP and YP are
actually the correct value before we
actually try to find the pixels value of
that index because if we do it at that
at an incorrect index it'll crash as you
know so if we launch this this time we
you'll see that we can actually move
around the map obviously the map right
now is limited to the size of our screen
because we actually haven't made a map
yet have we we've just made we've just
made it loop and we've just made a loop
enough times to actually be wise less
than height which is the height of our
spring and why then X is less than width
which is the width of our screen so we
made it go from 0 to width and from 0 to
5 right is 0 pi
zero with brilliant so the next step
which is what we're gonna actually cover
over the next few days is actually
making a level out of this so in other
words what we're actually gonna do is
first of all we're gonna you know set up
a way to actually define which tile is
which tile so in other words we'll
probably make some more textures like
rocks or flowers and we'll place them
around around the map will actually
create a map map creating system like
ellika a level editor I guess and we'll
also actually split this up into its own
level glass to cover that now one other
thing that I've noticed is if we
actually just hit the bug and we don't
click and we'll use the arrow keys we
can't actually move we actually have to
click first and then move and that's
because the window isn't InFocus by
default so to do that well the windows
in focus but the canvas inside the
window isn't in focus by default so to
fix that we can go to game the game drop
Java class and then we can go right up
here to the top of run and we'll just
put it like just before the water
running loop so just after all these
variables before the while running loop
will simply pull on one line of code
which is a request focus and that is it
and request focus is actually a
component I think it's from the
component class say that the canvas
class I'm guessing its component though
or just want even light up yet component
it's a method in the in the component
class which allows us to simply you know
open the game and look at that it gets
in focus straight away so yeah and you
can see that actually the movement is
correct so in other words if we go down
actually no it's not correct my bad
because if we go up it's sort of it's
actually moving the map up it's not
moving the play up but um yeah so that
is how we move around the screen and
tomorrow we're gonna start on an awesome
adventure on how to actually create our
own levels so until then guys hope you
enjoyed this episode of game programming
if you did please hit the like button
drop a comment you know let me know what
you thought and let me know what you
guys want me to do next well actually
we're gonna do levels next but you get
the drift if you guys want me to like
incorporate some special thing into the
game start planning ideas because real
soon I'm gonna start asking you guys
what you want the game to be like when
we actually get up to that
up to that point which is relatively
certain actually to um you know to
customize this game and really build it
based on what you guys what you guys
want Serb yeah until then guys goodbye
[Music]